hello and welcome to episode two of the
jake jordan and john luke podcast this
is a podcast only for people whose name
starts with jay so that's why it's just
wondering where you were gonna write
that when you were like episode two i'm
like holy [ __ ] it's uh it's a comeback
tour i would say
uh we good i think so okay cool i see
levels i think we're good levels we're
good all right uh no it's episode 160 of
game spot after dark tamora is busy lucy
is not feeling great
so it's us once again holding down the
fort
but i think that's okay because we got
plenty to talk about
uh we're gonna go through what we've
been playing we've got a couple topics
of the week that we want to
discuss
we've got our weekly question and
that'll probably wrap up the show
but before we get to that
i guess no we just start with what we've
been playing right yeah right
um
i mean i got a pretty bad paper cut
yesterday but that's probably not worth
talking about
i i got my my new computer monitor
finally showing oh yeah how is that oh
well if it showed up like an hour ago it
was supposed to arrive uh on monday and
fedex has been like doing that thing
where they keep saying like we tried to
deliver it but uh no one was there and i
was like [ __ ] you didn't call me i'm
here i am here there was someone always
there i think it's important is this a
replacement monitor is this a second
monitor replacement monitor so but it's
uh
wide ultra wide we're getting a nice
ultra wide monitor i i dished out for
the i think it's called the um alienware
cutie oled like a w something a lot of
words and letters it's a lot of words
and letters it's it's like their new uh
samsung's like new like
cutie oled technology so it's supposed
to look like really really good um it's
uh does like 175 hertz and all this like
nonsense and it really does really good
hdr for monitors which normally pc
monitors do like garbage hdr um you're
trying to live the single monitor life
too
because like my desk is not big enough
to support multiple monitors without
just quitters
i want you to do a video about that
single life monitor life because
that single life that single monitor
life because that's like a reality
because i very much want to downsize to
one ultra wide monitor because i'm sick
of having two i think the weird thing
will be like
having to get used to playing games and
ultra wide i've like dabbled with that
before but i've never like
owned a ultra wide it's always just been
like i've messed with it in the office
and i know like most modern games are
good about it but like playing older
games is going to be weird
or like capture like when if i have to
capture work i'll probably have to make
it sixteen by nine right like probably
probably even then suddenly everything
uh gamespot does is now ultra wide
um every single video
hey hugo in the chat says monitor arms
free up so much death space i got
monitor arms last year probably the best
investment i also have a monitor on my
desk it is so nice i just have so much
extra space and it looks so much nicer
the only thing i hate is that i've just
got a mess of wires under my desk yes my
why i'm gonna take this as an
opportunity to completely redo my cable
management because it's currently bad i
feel like arms though are like the
stepping stone stepping stone to like
then getting three monitors like it's
like
being like not for me i i can now like
put things like on top of other monitors
and uh because that's what happened to
tam like tam tam rocks like three
monitors setup is insane he has he also
has two microphones yeah like i don't
know oh yeah this is like recording
microphone and is like twitch streaming
uh yeah microphone and it's all in a
closet too which is
pretty cool yeah yeah it's like it's a
good setup but no i don't i jordan i
have a very small desk i just do not
have the space for all that if i had
like a really nice like big old desk
and like inject it into the wall and
have them
oh i've already i've
i have
look i we wall mounted our tv recently
and we messed it up and uh let me just
say that we have already destroyed the
deposits the deposit is probably gone
either that we're gonna have to get some
real heavy duty spackle to cover that
one up
um so the thing is
especially because you live in an
apartment building right not like so
they'll they're going to redo all those
walls anyway even if you didn't do much
damage to them they are going to go
through and repair them yeah they're
probably going to charge you more
because there is damage but i don't
think it's going to mess things up no
unless you have like full-on holes
through the drywall then that like like
fist size holes through the drywall i'm
not talking little holes sure there is
one
there's a big old nail i have to pull
out of the wall let's just say that okay
a big old nail yeah
let's just put it that way
i'm worried i'm a little worried about
that but otherwise yeah it'll be good um
serious business is also in the chat
mentions did you guys see the new
samsung 34 curved monitor with built-in
xbox cloud games really nice that's
pretty cool
it also has stadia in it which i find is
funny yeah
i saw like the weird cause sorry what
it's got what
there's a this new uh technology that's
gonna take over the world
google's really getting into it
interesting i've never never heard of
that yeah is that oh is that is that
like a future of cloud gaming they said
is that like luma is that you know yeah
i think it's like similar spheres like
they're gonna dominate the space
together copying amazon huh
is there's a question for you is stadia
the
the uh uh plural of stadium
are you asking this to me because i'm
like you're you're an editor yeah you're
an editor that's what i'm asking you i
was watching i was watching what's it
called welcome to rex ham i don't know
if you guys know this but it's rob
mcillenny and ryan reynolds bought in uh
for a
club soccer team in
in in wrexham oh yeah and there's a
point where they say it's one of the
oldest stadia's in the world or stadia
in the world and i was like
i've never heard someone use that word
apart from
the stadia google or yeah whatever
google stadia
so i don't know is that what they call
this stadium cause like i figured like
multiple stadiums that are like media is
indeed the correct latin plural of
stadium it is however far more common
for english speakers to use stadiums
interesting
how does that relate to cloud gaming i'm
trying to think i'm trying to think of
the
google looked and it's like you know
what would be the perfect word for cloud
gaming the plural form of stadium to be
fair it's not a bad name no it's just
didn't didn't it's just not a great
service yeah it's okay
the most i would use it for a shout out
to david ahmadi um who
uh would buy
cheap uh stadia uh subscriptions i'm
calling him out so hard right now so
that he could log into
destiny which had its um
own like version on stadia that was
unique to itself like the player base
was entirely contained within stadia so
there were less people so he would use
it to get easy wins and trials of osiris
so he could get like all the way to the
lighthouse i'm calling him the [ __ ] out
he's using the internet here too the
high speed
gigabyte internet and everyone's trying
to make it work on their crappy internet
mm-hmm
jeez
you can't do that trick anymore i think
they folded it in with pc yeah probably
anyway should we talk about what we've
been playing yeah i've you've been
playing a big one i've been playing a
big one do we want to start with the
last of us do we want to end on the last
of us how do how do we feel hmm i mean
you've already mentioned it i feel like
we should just dive into tell you that's
exactly how we did it last time
yeah just started right well
i reviewed the last of us yeah the
review's there
uh people can read it if they want
probably more condensed thoughts because
i might go on tangents every now and
then
what's the score tell me the score
score's an eight okay yeah and then you
don't need to talk anymore i know the
score now yeah that's it
was an objective we're good move on
um that was an interesting review not to
get too inside baseball but we already
have a last of us review that was
written a long time ago sure by tom
mcshea
uh we have a review for left behind
which was also written by tom mcshay a
long time ago i think we did an updated
review for the remastered version
and originally we were going to do an
updated review for
this one
this remake but i ended up having a lot
to say
so we turned it into a full review but
it's still an eight even though my
personal like
this is where it gets tricky because
gamespot scale
it's an eight but my scale i love the
last one of my favorite games of all
time
uh
this remake is very good uh it it
makes an already really good game even
better
it doesn't do a whole lot of different
things um
which i know it bums out some people and
to an extent it bums me out most
particularly some of the puzzles that
kind of suck are still there however
thanks to all the accessibility stuff if
you want to play lassos but don't want
to do the puzzles you can just skip them
you can skip right saw that option which
is something i didn't mention in the
review and i and i kind of regret it
because like i think my point still
stands about like hey it's kind of dated
that i'm pushing ellie around on a
pallet and it's weird that joel never
taught her how to swim through the
course of this very or every time you
have to grab a dumpster every time
you're going across the country and they
just
like
like
it's cool you can skip that stuff and i
understand why people would but even
though i don't like it i never would
because it's that whole experience i
think
it was designed to be a part of the game
exactly
um
but yeah i mean
it's
it's the last of us if you really like
the last of us you're probably really
gonna like this if you played the last
of us already and you don't really think
you need to replay it then it's probably
not not your kind of thing you know it's
like if you like it
go for it if you don't the the big thing
missing is is um multiplayer which i'm
bummed about because yeah i did play a
lot of factions when it came out and i
know naughty dog is working on
a like full-fledged multiplayer last of
us game which is cool but i think
there's something to be said about like
that the the history like preserving
that mode in some form and you can still
technically play it now
but
yeah i i i don't know it it it does feel
like a bummer i'm with you i i felt the
same way about the uncharted collection
which
didn't include the multiplayer for two
and three that i love personally yeah
and those they shut those down a couple
years ago um so
that's you just can't play this anymore
yeah it's like a real bummer the mass
effect legendary edition as well didn't
bring back mass effect 3 multiplayer
yeah yeah right yeah what's up with that
that was even weirder because that was
tied to the campaign and yeah
it was weird because it's stupidly
popular yeah
it was weird because you could still go
to those stages in single player like
there was those little missions you
could do but you couldn't actually do
multiplayer stuff which is kind of a
bummer um
but yeah i mean
i i get the argument that like this
didn't fundamentally change enough but i
am kind of of the camp that i don't
think it necessarily needed to i think
that story is so strong those characters
are so good
and john looks smashing things
uh i disagree
and and i think like the
the the facelifts all the characters
have had actually add a lot to
the story i mean not obviously it's not
going to change your your your idea of
these characters or recontextualize them
but i think
if you look at the playstation 3 version
those characters didn't look as good as
you remember them uh no well because i
even when i saw the last of us announced
last was probably one announcement i was
like last of us looks really good still
like it doesn't need this and then you
go back and then i went back to play it
and i was like whoa like some of the
environments in the last of us
original still look pretty good but even
then that because because i was helping
capture uh the original ps3 version for
you which um
when i was playing it at the time for
like i was just like dang this game
holds up really well like you know like
just playing it i was like wow this
still looks really good and i do believe
like
that game artistically was like way
ahead of its time like pushing pushed
the ps3 to its absolute limit and that's
it my ps3 was loud when i was playing
about right it was struggling
that was a game that i know they wanted
to get it out for ps3 but i'm like man
this was definitely a ps4 like oh yeah
it was uh struggling to hit hit that
that 30 frames a lot of times when i was
capping but
i was like yeah this holds up really
well and i was kind of like shocked how
good it looked and then
i played a little bit of the ps5 version
uh at the office here for the uh
graphics comparison and i was like holy
crap these environments look crazy
because if you go and look at our
graphics comparison we have up on
youtube
it it's
because it's like yeah the faces are
like sure that's an obvious thing you
can look at but like they completely
redid a lot of the architecture of the
buildings and the streets and
they have this level of
detail to them that
i found myself like sucked in more and
feeling more like a real place
um
not to say like you know that like like
the original game like doesn't do that
but it's just like that i think it
elevates that stuff in a way that is is
to me meaningful at least you know yeah
it really does and i i think that is
another reason why a lot of those
puzzles stand out even more to me
because
the game
in theory right when you look at the
visuals even the gameplay i think is is
is much better than it was in the
original uh the game feels better it
looks better but then you get to these
puzzles and it just it it feels like a
game from 2013 i mean
generations ago even at the time yeah i
remember being like okay these dumpster
puzzles are kind of dumb but this is
still one of my favorite games of all
time and now like it's a little harder
to justify that yeah again after all of
this time
um
all that said though like
it i it it's a really good remake i
would say um and if you haven't played
the last of us i would
i don't think you would regret paying 70
dollars for this sure you could if
you're a playstation plus subscriber you
could play the last of us remastered for
free if you have playstation plus
but like
i don't know if you've never played last
of us and you want to go from last of us
one to two i would
if if it's if it's within your means i
would strongly consider or just wait
or wait that's the other thing too like
in a couple months this is probably
going to be added to
what is it extra premium right exactly
one of those
or again i mean also the holiday season
is coming up so like black friday like
some some store is going to sell it at a
discount yeah like that's the easiest
they're not nintendo the price is gonna
exactly
to me that's like
if that's how you feel about like you
know if you very strongly feel like hey
i don't agree with the pricing of this
and think sony's being greedy or
whatever like that's the way to prove it
yeah either don't buy it or buy it on
sale and sony will see those numbers and
say wow way more people bought it on
sale than they did you know 70 dollars
so maybe maybe that pricing didn't make
sense or maybe they won't care you know
who knows and and i mean it's weird for
me to talk too much about pricing right
because sony provided me with a code to
review the game
but i did buy the game like i bought it
on ps5 because i was like i
want this game because i really like it
and if a friend hasn't played it i want
to be like hey you just got a ps5 you
got to play last of us here's my copy
you know i do kind of want to buy a
physical version of it just so i can
have part one and part two like next
week
i thought about i thought about this i i
i have a suspicion that i think there
was a leak a while ago we'll do a
that they were going to do a like
director's cut of last of us part two
which
might make sense because it sounds like
there was a lot that was cut but this
game is already so [ __ ] long it's
such a long game and i'm like
the pacing that games i think is weird i
remember because like one of the rumors
was like oh in the director's cut they
might like interchange it that it will
be in part two it'll be
la day one abby day one led
kind two cool you get to experience like
the
days simultaneously i wonder how that
would change it because i assume at some
point the devs tested it that way like
someone was like should we at least try
it and they like went through it and
like ah it just doesn't work as well as
yeah cause because i think the shock of
like fully switching halfway through
worked really well but then i also
wonder like if you know
going in
like if you've got if you're gonna see
like both stories ramping up the same
time and then like
yeah ellie's day three ends on that
cliffhanger and it goes immediately into
abby's day three and it hits that like
button that would be an interesting
experiment i'm curious to see yeah
maybe like a remix last of us part two
remix just yeah just let us order it any
way we want
to make our own story yeah yeah exactly
but but that said i i imagine i don't
know within the next couple years i
think there's going to be like a last of
us complete box set or whatever that
people are going to do
part one part two
um
maybe some extra
you know stuff but but
it comes with a beta code for uh
yeah probably it'll come with a beta
code for for the multi-factor
um i will say if you still are on the
fence you read the review and you're not
really sure i did another video that i
think is out yes uh yeah because we
ended up putting out today that
basically just goes over all the new
stuff that they added and there's quite
a bit like
nothing that fundamentally changes the
game but there's things like permadeath
they added um there's a bunch of extras
you can unlock some gameplay
some gameplay modifiers you can use i i
personally really liked playing with
permadeath you can set it for either
reset the game when you die reset the
act or the season i guess or reset the
chapter and i did chapter for the second
playthrough and that was kind of fun it
it fits the themes of the game it adds
more
tension to the combat which is already
pretty tense but like yeah that risk
makes it even tougher um
not tougher but it makes it makes it
even more engaging i would say
um
but yeah uh i liked it i'm excited to
play it i'm definitely gonna pick it up
um i wasn't like a hundred percent sure
not because i
just because i was like well i've played
the last of us
a fair amount of time do i want to play
it again but it has been a really long
time like because i didn't i i'd like
started replaying it right before two
but i ended up like not
i only got like a like a couple hours in
and stopped so i never like fully
experienced it again recently
and
like replaying a little bit of the ps3
version for the graphics comparison and
then kind of like you know just reading
your review and stuff i was like
yeah i think i would really like to play
this game again yeah so i'm definitely
looking forward to it i will say
if you plan if you've already played
last of us you want this and you're
picking it up this goes for you as well
i mean jordan i don't know if you
planned it or not but i would do custom
difficulty settings do not just pick a
regular difficulty i was thinking about
custom difficulty settings crank up
enemy ai as high as you can um you can
you can make yourself as like
as fragile or spongy as you want like
like do whatever you want but i i
genuinely think that if you play with
the stupidest ai
you're missing out because part of the
fun of combat not even the fun but just
the believability of that world is just
how tenacious these enemies are and and
i feel like you are genuinely missing
part of that experience when you're not
being flanked you're not being pressured
enemies aren't hiding from you and
jumping out at you and stuff like that
that
that changes the pace of combat
dramatically yeah um
which which which i think is really neat
and like i've always loved the combat
for last of us i know it's kind of it's
not everyone's cup of tea and i get why
because it's brutal and it can be hard
to watch but like i find it really
intense
um so so i would say like
if you pick it up like crank up that ai
as much as you can the rest whatever you
think suits me those unbreakable shoes
yeah yeah like you can do that if you
want like
look i don't want to do the slow choke
out
yeah
yeah i'd probably turn high ai and then
i'd probably turn the like
joel listening
off because i remember playing i did
play like the grounded mode on uh
ps3 and i remember really really liking
that mode it's good it's frustrating but
it's good yeah like don't do permadeath
and grounded whoever does that is
right there but yeah i find myself not
liking um
like weird batman vision and games i
feel like it's just
especially if they don't make sense like
if there's context i get it but in last
of us that was when that game came out i
was like this is really dumb i'm not
going to use this and i just didn't you
know it feels more like a crutch rather
than like a game did that first
i mean
is it batman because everyone calls it
batman vision i feel like because it's
batman
batman did it and then everyone it
appeared in like every game sense
because i'm like i can't remember if
batman did it first or if assassin's
creed did their eagle vision uh first
and it feels like batman's is kind of
like a play off of but i think batman's
is more because it can see through walls
prominent you can like see through walls
and also i think because in batman it
was like well i'm just going to keep
this on for 90 of the game and not look
at the beautiful art and like yeah
that's just no fun i i do love it though
when a game gives context to that sort
of stuff i'm trying to think of a good
one but like
um i mean batman obviously makes sense
because he's got it
he's got all of this
is his technique
yeah they were like witcher senses yeah
kind of i feel like
a little video gamey i was expecting it
in cyberpunk like oh you can get
cybernetics that will like
like i want an improved map so i'm gonna
get like a different eye that gives me a
better map and gives me a better
heads-up display like that that stuff
and that would have made sense like oh
there's cameras everywhere you're just
passively hacking into everything and
just seeing through uh like in context
in context huds i think are i think are
pretty cool sure yeah um but but even
like visions and stuff but but yeah i
would i wouldn't play last of us with
with with uh listening mode i will say
too if you want to go for the platinums
and you're doing custom
uh difficulty you don't need to beat it
on any difficulty to get um
plat you can you can beat it on whatever
you want so i would set uh your
resources to high because if you do
grounded you will not be able to open
all of the shift doors i promise you
because i did it and i always
find a way nothing makes me more
frustrated than getting to like i have
almost enough to make a shift but i
don't and i search the area tirelessly
and there's nothing and i'm just like
well guess we're moving on i'm leaving
this door unopened and i hate it
anyway that's last of us cool i feel
like i've talked enough about last of us
to last me for uh you know another eight
years or so so when partners when it
comes out oh what's gonna say when they
remake it again when they remake it now
that we make part two in eight years
[Laughter]
um the other game that i've played
you've also been playing john is
immortality i will say i don't think we
should say too much about it yeah i kind
of want to talk about
i don't know yeah i'm struggling to
think about what i want to say about it
because it's
really damn good i mean you can kind of
just say that it's like it's a good game
everyone can
so for those who aren't aware of
immortality it is the new game by sam
barlow who is known for her story and
telling lies i played her story i didn't
play telling lies i heard it wasn't as
good um so i skipped that one but um you
know he's kind of known for these games
that like use fnv
and it uh where like that's kind of the
way you tell the story and it's sort of
unconventional in the case of both
her story in this game you are
essentially given like a bunch of
different footage that you can kind of
put together
uh into trying to like basically piece
together what happened like that's the
point of the game is to just sort of
figure out
what's going on with these characters uh
and i absolutely [ __ ] love the setup
for this game it's essentially about
this woman named marissa marcel who is
like an actress
who
um
famously she's not real person but like
in the fiction of this game although
we'll get into that we'll get into the
weirdness of that so
she famously starred in three movies
none of which were ever released
and then
disappeared after that no one knows what
happened to her
and there's this really like great uh
about page like on the main menu where
it's like a brief history of marissa
marcel by sam barlow and it's like this
wikipedia like explaining like who she
was and how she was in these three
movies and she disappeared and they're
like
recently in 2020 like people discovered
like boxes of archival footage from like
the three movies and we have put
together this interactive like uh piece
of media for you to be able to like
scrub through and look at all these
movies so i love the idea of like you
could do but i love the idea something
like we found this like lost all this
lost footage we want to share with the
world we're gonna give it to the world
in these pieces that they have to
well well because it's like none of the
movies were finished so it's all like
you know essentially like when you find
like reels right yeah and it's just like
multiple takes of scenes and multiple
takes of scenes most of the scenes don't
have like audio treatment on them uh
which is like great it's it this is like
an absolute editor's like dream game
like i'm just like living off of this i
see why you jake and all like
i mean i like that i also like like i
love fmv games like i adore fmv games
and i think this is a really good one
um
but i so i love that it is
it leans really hard into the idea that
like the game never breaks from the idea
that all of this is fictional like to
the point where as kurt told me this
morning
if you go on wikipedia imdb imdb sorry
yes imdb if you go on imdb you can find
all three of the fictional movies on
imdb
with the listed actors like the fake
actors
in the game as the actors in the movies
i don't know how they did it
i was just about to ask them like can
you submit stuff to imdb and like jake
was saying that's very difficult to do
well it's not that it's difficult it's
just
okay i haven't done this process in a
long time i used to do for short films
when i was in college and basically
with imdb you have to have like a movie
that has been into film festival so it
can be confirmed as an actual movie and
then it'll show up there now there are
exceptions like i think like ign has
some shows that are technically on imdb
and stuff but but not anyone can just be
like i'm going to make an imdb page for
this movie at least at the time that may
have changed now because i haven't well
i'm wondering what maybe somebody loves
three of these movies actually exist and
they just spliced up pieces of them for
this game could you just submit those
completed films so that's kind of my
guess that i think these were
actual
these movies were actually made cut
together
and
submitted to something i
i just somewhere out there i just
watched the film festival
i just watched an episode of nathan for
you which i don't know if you guys have
seen
but it's uh nathan fielder and he
basically goes to businesses and and
comes up with these ridiculous
strategies but one of his one of his
business proposals was to make a made-up
um film award so he could give his film
an award so it could be considered an
actual film so maybe sam barlow made his
own
film festival in order to play the make
his movies because
that would be
i don't know like would that be cooler
if these ones actually showed up in film
festivals at some point and people like
years ago people had no idea
i would love for you
to do this as an investigative like
report thing like does it figure out
like how is this possible how is there
although i do wonder if there is actual
enough footage if they filmed all the
footage because there are some scenes
where instead of getting
the scene as it was shot you'll get like
the table reading for the scene instead
so they didn't like
shoot
every scene or maybe they did but they
didn't put it all in the game
which is like but like that's that's
where it gets really interesting because
it's not just like you're watching the
scene from the movie you're watching
the table readings
you're watching like the casting call
stuff you're watching like the behind
the scenes where the actors are like
celebrating you'll watch um
the first thing you watch is like a like
late night like talk show like interview
with marissa marcel like talking you
know to like a david letterman type
where they're about like the movie she
was just in
so you're getting all these weird pieces
around these movies
and it
basically at any point when so you start
with like a couple clips and then at any
point
you can
pause and you can rewind you can scrub
through you can you can do all these
things and you can
uh
kind of like click around with your
cursor and when you see something where
like the cursor will kind of give like a
little eye icon it basically means you
can click on that and then it'll
essentially find a connecting thing and
like it'll match kind of match cut to a
different scene
so for example
for me
i started with the interview where she's
talking to the to the talk show host and
then i clicked on the head of the talk
show host and it suddenly cut to a
different clip of that talk show host a
lot older interviewing somebody else
about a different movie
and so like you're kind of going through
that it's not just people there will be
um
so my favorite
i talked to kurt about this occurred did
it too
is like i was trying to test the limits
of like what can i click on
and um so this movie or this game has a
lot of nudity in it by the way it's very
it's luke there's a lot of nudity i
don't think i've seen any really i've
seen
so much
that's all
anyway so there was a scene where
uh
uh someone like flashes one of their
tits and i haven't seen this and and
then i and then
and i paused it and i said
can i click on that
and i clicked on it and it zooms in and
then zooms out to reveal a different
set of a different set of tits in a
different scene and then i was like
this is game of the year material
everyone let's go uh
i i've played a couple hours i think
it's probably one of the coolest
closest game like detective like games
i've played yes cause
it really does a good one like that in a
while yeah like like the best i can
think of is return to obra den sure yes
yeah it doesn't give you a lot to work
with when you start it's just kind of
like hey
look through these and and you really
have to piece the stories to all these
different movies together but on top of
that you also have to piece together the
story of this actress who you only see
um like in very rare like normally
she'll be playing a character but
beforehand before they slayed it and
after they cut though you'll get like a
little glimpse of who she actually is
yes so you're trying to piece together
the narrative to what there's three or
four films three films there's three
films that that that you're getting
scenes from and then you're getting bits
of her after but then there's also a
bunch of other characters you're trying
to figure out yeah
like how they fit together in this story
it's really neat i will say
i found it very hard to follow along
just because
you have to be like this like person per
story like i should have like a notebook
100 percent yeah there are some
detective games like they're death loop
and forgotten city they're like oh we'll
keep notes
i don't know if you know this is jake
but even in the tutorial there was a
little thing that happened in the
tutorial like the first thing that pops
up
i noticed something was off and i
immediately turned to georgia and said
grab the notebook we're writing
everything down
i was like oh this is one of these guys
grab the notebook and it's funny because
like i i start to over analyze
everything like there was a moment where
a character like stammered their line oh
yeah and it kind of sounded like a um
it almost sounded like an awkward cut
and i was like is that a thing is that
important should i take notes write that
down
it's just like weird stuff like that
i'll come up with patterns in my own
head too that aren't necessarily true
like someone will look at the camera
again they did it again that's something
yeah and then it's nothing like all
right it's just that guy just looks at
the camera too much
uh but there is without getting into it
it
there's some surprising stuff that
happens that i was like not expecting
and i was yeah like whoa
ahead of the three-day weekend where
i'll have creepy creepy creepy i would
say it's not like it's not a horror game
necessarily but it is unnerving it's
unnerving some very unnerving stuff that
happens and just because all it is is
just you're watching this footage and
like there's barely
there's no music attached to the footage
but there is music that'll play in the
game as you're watching it and like
sometimes it gets
real creepy and you're like uh
but
because yeah it's like i i think kind of
like what you were saying jake it's
definitely a game where it's like if you
need like
a level of
hand holdings maybe not the right term
but just like some sort of direction to
go in you might struggle with this game
because this game gives you
absolutely zero direction it very much
expects you to figure out but that's
what i find fast the dude's done this
like with all of his games so far so i
think this is his name this is by far
the most successful because the level of
production
is like on oh the most successful
because a lot of people are like oh the
second one's not as good as uh
her story telling and i couldn't tell
you because i again i didn't play it but
like telling her story was great but
it's also like it's just a woman in like
a room it's very simple where this is
like you have all these actors in these
sets and these scenes and
the acting is like
i'm starting with kurt about this where
where
the thing with like fmv games is that
when you play them you kind of know that
like these are sort of like
really low tier productions like you
know they're kind of intentionally like
cheap and and and a lot of times they
kind of lean into the hamminess of it to
for you know uh to make it more
entertaining but it's like they're
working with the very
limitations of what they are and and so
you they end up being very cheesy and
comedic and yeah hammy feels a little
lynchian yes i would say this has i
would say a stronger
a much stronger like production to it um
where i found myself
believing
all of these actors but it's not just
i'm watching these actors you know i'm
watching these scenes i'm watching these
actors act scenes so it's actors acting
as actors
acting as scenes
and then you have like
a director
in the scene
doing a table reading with his actors
but then there's an actual director
directing this director to direct his
actors and you're like
what the [ __ ] like but but they they
pull it off like at no point like did i
ever like
i i haven't had a scene yet where it
felt like the
uh illusion was broken like i believed
it the whole time like it really sucks
you into it and you're like i believe
that these are actors making a movie
which they are kind of but it's like
it's like it's really
just the production behind it
fascinates me it's so interesting
and and
um
it's that kind of game you want to talk
about with everyone like i you know i've
been playing with my girlfriend georgia
and you know we were just like oh what's
this mean what's that and then i was
like so excited when i came in today and
i saw kurt was at his desk and i had to
immediately go over it and just talk to
him about it because i was like i just
need i just need to talk about
everything that happened in this and
because of how freeform it is like
everyone has a completely different
experience in like how they discover
stuff like yeah i think the inciting
moment for me was different from you
the exciting most different from kurt
like yes i told kurt when i was like had
the moment had the moment he was like
yeah i did that mine was different
yeah yeah your moment will be different
and then or even like an interesting one
again all as vague as possible but there
is a like
a part of the mystery is like why did
each film not be released you know you
like know that up front that none of
these films release but you're like why
did none of them get released it's odd
for three films and so
i happened to
go to a clip
that immediately explained why the
second film wasn't released so i knew
right away
um and then when i was watching the
footage for the second film i had that
context and so i was like thinking about
that the whole time i was watching it
right and like okay i know why this
second film wasn't made and i was
looking for like the like
based on that information and the
inciting incident people looking at each
other and like piecing that together
kurt however
did not know
what the
reason the movie didn't get made or
didn't get released to until he got to
the scene
that shows you why so he
watched the majority thing got to that
scene and then was like
what the [ __ ] is happening and like
wasn't even sure if it was real
if that makes sense i'm being so vague
here but basically it's just like i find
that so cool that like
you can just have such a vastly
different experience in like the way
this game is presented to you but it
still works and like that's like the the
most genius like thing about this is
that
like
it should break right like you should
have like this weird thing where like i
mean maybe it's possible right like
maybe someone could just happen to like
click on the right things and get to the
ending like crazy fast my sure
probability will happen to somebody but
at least so far like i think it's just
like the way
you're able to like naturally piece
everything together
no matter what path you take
is like is just like nothing sort of
brilliant
although i think
in one of the interviews like for her
story like they were talking about like
oh we designed the information in such a
way that if you did accidentally click
on very relevant stuff early on that
like it would be
like the search results that you would
get like the more important stuff would
be like regulated to the bottom you'd be
less likely to click on it yeah so i
assume with this game something else has
like been similarly implemented with
like the game works to make sure that
you don't get all the most important
stuff right out of the gate that that
inciting moment that i referenced i kind
of think that
that only happens after you've seen a
certain amount of clips
so i think the reason why we all have
different ones is because maybe you saw
a clip that that much earlier than i did
and that was the one like i don't know
it's like keeping track in the back does
that mean that like earlier clips if i
go back to them those things will appear
i don't know
oh i have to go back and watch every
scene now also like just
just playing it last night i'm like
cycling through clips and i'm like
my controller vibrated differently on
this one and then i'm doing it a hundred
times i'm like i can't tell is that the
same or is that different should i watch
this video
what and like it's doesn't matter any
jake in a dark room just staring at a
screen just like your friend yeah it's
like you get into that mode
before we move on i just want to shout
out mark delaney reviewed this game for
us he gave it an eight
um
so the entire review is basically like i
can't explain to you why this game is as
good as it is you just have to trust me
yeah yeah
his we'll just go to the plus and
minuses the good drenched in mystery
that player that the player unravels at
their own pace fantastic performances in
production make for an authentic
time-hopping story scarier than it lets
on clearly subverts its own niche genre
the bad one thing which is which is what
i agree with and why i was having
trouble getting into it so dense and
mystery misdirection that it can often
feel impenetrable and i
for me i would say that's a pretty
that that that is true if you don't lie
right from the get-go because the first
night i played it i played for about an
hour and a half and i was tired and i
was like i can't do this game i cannot
figure out
all of these different movies that are
happening and all these different
characters and then i came into the
office and kurt was talking about it and
i was like i never figured out what this
did and he's like well i'm not going to
tell you
now i know it's uh then i went home and
played more and i was like okay this
game's cool it's definitely not a game
for everyone but
i think if like what we have said
intrigues you
you should absolutely play because like
yeah for me it was like with it i'm
gonna try it within minutes i was like
yes yes this is my jam and it's on game
pass so it's just it's on game pass game
pass if you have game pass you can play
it for free
free um i just it feels weird to say
like it's free on game pass like
technically not technically not but
included with game pass yes it's
probably a better way to put it
um great game though
jordan you got to check out flintlock
the siege of dawn yes it is the
sophomore effort of a44 games who made
ash a little souls-like that came out in
december of
2018 uh and i feel like got like quickly
overlooked just because that's just a
hard time uh to come out but like
checking out flintlock wait ash in the
souls
like yeah souls like with guns
well oh flintlocks alone
with more
guns action had guns too it did have
guns but i think oh that has a
completely different art style right am
i crazy
ashen looks kind of like actions like
post-apocalyptic isn't it
it is post-apocalyptic it looks like
that uh
absolver the game before yeah
i know you're thinking of um ashton does
not have guns i was thinking of that
other one too i forget what it's called
continue i'm gonna it
no that is right yeah that's what you
think yeah yeah this is yeah
yeah but the art style with the
flintlock looks completely different oh
it's completely different they're like
yeah yeah we're doing like a new engine
for like a more realistic face okay okay
like art style um
they hired a linguist to make like an
entirely new language for the gods and
stuff like that i'm like man y'all are
just like oh we took the
like little bit of success we had with
the first game we're just going
all out with this uh not second one rude
to those devs i'm because i'm sure they
worked very hard on their new engine i
kind of like the way ashen looked better
fashion was really i think action has a
more unique style art style
and
it's going to be one of those things
where i'm like oh
flintlock looks very
pretty but like one of the things is
like trying to like get screenshots from
the gameplay of flintlock was like
really hard because every time you like
tried to slow down the game at
yeah and i'm like so this game might not
be as pretty when we're actually playing
it on consoles in 2023 as it like looks
in its presentations but that's neither
here nor there but it's one of those
things that while i was looking at the
gameplay and talking to the devs i'm
like you can kind of
follow the exact like inspiration line
of what it is because you are playing as
someone
who only wields an axe
has a companion who like aids them in
battle
and then uses a combat system where you
are there's the health bar and then
there's a little yellow bar where you're
trying to like hit someone enough times
to like break their armor down so you
can land like a strong execution kill
i'm like
well actually came out in late 2018 i'm
like god of war was like the talk of the
town and sakura was like three months
away from coming out i'm like this game
looks like
god of wars like relationship within
like the combat style of
sakura
um
uh there's even like a bunch of stuff
where it's like oh yeah you can like use
gum powder like to easily uh get up to
like the top of buildings like jump down
on people and like hit them from above
i'm like this is
and they're like we don't really know of
many games that put like really advanced
like mechanisms and like gunpowder and
stuff like that like in fantasy worlds
i'm like sakura sakura is a game that
puts like
mechanisms and gunpowder into a fantasy
world um and like i i'm sure like that
they were thinking about this like
before sakura even came out but it is
one of those things that just looking at
the gameplay for it i was like
oh they're
calling their like ally to like do
different elemental attacks and like
stun the enemies and uh nor the
protagonist is like doing different axe
attacks like uh tossing it or like
charging it up to do like a stronger
strike and the axe is glowing and like
this is very god of war and then when
she's fighting it's like one of those
things where it's like oh yeah like
you're chipping away and like the armor
bar is like filling up and when it's
completely filled she can like do the
execution thing on many bosses and
bosses you have to do it like several
times to
finish them off and
so it's one of those things that i'm
like
okay this is really cool that you guys
are like using inspiration from like two
very cool games that i like a lot at the
same time it almost feels
a little too close at like what's it
doing yeah um and i'm like yeah i'm like
what about this game is specifically
unique enough that i'm like oh i
definitely want to play this game
instead of just going back and playing
2018's god of war or sakura
again one thing that seems kind of
interesting though that stood out to me
was that
that that traveling camp that you have
with you
did you get a sense on how that works
like do you set that up where you want
or is it as you progress the story does
it appear in different places so for
those don't know basically there's a
camp right that like basically brings
important stuff with you like npcs right
you can i don't know what you can do
there i just cause like you're a part of
this army and so like there's this camp
of people who are with you as you meet
new characters they like join your camp
and your camp gets bigger and ashen had
this too where like at the very
beginning of the game you
defeated these bandits took over their
camp and as you met people in the world
they would come back to your camp and
like they would open up shops and pave
roads and build all that stuff is really
cool to me yeah but in this one it's
more like oh no instead of it being the
hub area is always back at a certain
place the hub area is kind of following
you through the world on the
adventure and they didn't show us
exactly how that would work we got to
actually we saw what the encampment
looked like and it was pretty cool it
was like these tents and like there were
these animals and like other characters
that like knew who nor was and like they
were talking about like past adventures
and so i'm like oh so there's probably
something where this evolves and grows
and that's really cool but they didn't
quite show us exactly like okay
so at what point
in the story does nor get far enough
that like this just picks up and like
moves to an entirely new location is it
like every bonfire type thing that you
come across is it like further apart
than that and they didn't really talk
about that too much but i am also very
excited to learn more about that because
my favorite part of ash and was the
whole like
community building aspect of it so
to see them kind of be like oh we're
gonna do that again yeah um
just for the record the game i was
thinking of was remnant from the ashes
not action but from the ashes
which is also souls like
that's multiplayer and there's guns
um
but but yeah flintlock seems interesting
i i watched some of the gameplay and
it
i'm worried about how it's gonna feel
based on what i've seen and i feel bad
because
souls games always feel so good and i i
know they're very hard to replicate that
feeling and to an extent you don't want
to replicate that feeling but that makes
it really hard for me to get into souls
likes because it's just
this is cool but i'd rather just play
secured rather i mean sakura
maybe not a soul's like but i just
rather play elden ring or bloodborne or
dark souls or
some folks who do it the best like yeah
but like i'm curious i mean like
i think it's the other systems right for
me that like need to really stand out to
get me to play a souls like and it seems
like this game could do it um mostly
with the camp stuff also the
the the
baristas look pretty [ __ ] cool
the like uh ones with it's so weird
because it was like oh yeah and there
are coffee shops and like stuff i must
have missed her in like coffee shop like
in seoul's like and you go into like
these little shops and it's like this
just crumpled cloak with like this
porcelain mask there and all of a sudden
like these eight arms reach out from the
cloak and two of them pick up the
porcelain mask and like hold it up while
the other arms are like mixing coffee
for the patrons or like communicating in
sign language since it's a porcelain
mask and the person doesn't have a face
and that's like your fast travel points
where you can also like meet other
people who are like also attending the
coffee shop and like hear gossip for
like side missions and stuff like that
to go out into the open world and that's
complete things i love that but i'm like
that's
an interesting like
barista or it's like oh there's the
cloak that's pretty cool it's like oh my
god you're a body of nothing but arms
what do they connect to like
what's underneath the cloak i want to
know
you don't want to know
um anything else you want to add about
flintlock that before we move on uh no
i'm excited for it i'm curious just to
see what it's going to be like we're
supposed to go out this year i was
originally going to they delayed it to
early 2020 okay so
february yeah february 23rd that's the
day everything's coming out sure yeah
just starting to throw it in there it's
february 23rd remember when everything
was supposed to come out february of
2022 and thankfully like three different
things got delayed again yeah yeah
let's hope that happens because jesus is
crazy i feel like it's wrong it's
supposed to come out in february yeah
something like that it's not even just
like
are you guys hurting yourselves by just
everyone putting all their games out at
once like
sonic doesn't care sonic's like we will
absolutely come out the same day
this got a war
yeah they're quoting a different
marketing yes
still that is weird before we move on
john luke you have played destiny 2 king
fault king's fall raid oh yeah the the
reprise raid
destiny 2 came out over the weekend
played that
still really damn good destiny 2 still
good destiny 2 still good that raid's
really good that really is seven years
old and i was like jesus i can't believe
it's been that long since that raid came
out destiny doesn't even feel that old
no i mean destiny 2 is now 5 years old
yeah that doesn't i don't like i don't
like that one bit i don't like i know
right yeah
it says something because you like uh
like you look at that game and i think
mostly because of the art direction like
it still looks really good and still
probably the best feeling shooter it
looks like a late-gen
shooter from last chat like it looks
yeah it holds uh and on pc obviously it
looks better but totally
uh but yeah the king's fall raid was
a lot of fun um i didn't i didn't go for
like the day one race thing because i
was like no i'm not doing that um
well they also released it on friday
instead of the usual saturday because um
to be fair they were like
um we would like our employees to not
have to work the weekend to solve
potential like technical issues if the
raid happens
so uh i can't really be mad at them for
that but i was like
yeah i i can't i can't do that i got
work
but uh but it was good it was it was
really fun it's still a great raid and
like i mean the art direction of that
game like of that raid holds up
beautifully uh it's so much fun and
uh yeah like i i didn't get a single
weapon drop which was fun i did i did
get the full armor set though so i'm
rocking that which is cool but
uh i'm very excited to eventually take
you
i i want to do raids i mean that's
probably the main reason why i've gotten
back in destiny is because i only played
vault of glass and i thought it was so
much [ __ ] fun
but i just
then on i either haven't been raid ready
or i just haven't had enough people to
do it and i remember the first raid in
destiny 2. i was trying so hard to get
raid ready and i ended up being out of
the country when you guys actually ran
out of the office and i was like come on
i'm ready this time like i i
spent so much time just getting raid
ready and and i couldn't do it so i i
want to go back and do some of those
rates because well not that one was that
one they took out of the game
unfortunately
would i play to that raid i remember
liking vault of glass more it's good
it's it's but it's probably one of my
weaker weaker ones and fault the glass
is good too but also
um i imagine their level design for
raids yeah it would be it would be it
would be sad if vaulted glass is still
like one of the best raids because it
was the first one yeah
but uh yeah i think oh no maybe i did
what was the second raid the second raid
was crotizen that's a really short one i
may have done that one then
okay i vaguely remember a giant god's
face
and i was shading god's face yeah it
could have been king's fall
maybe it was king's fault maybe kings
falls over when i played maybe i should
play kingston is real good yeah we'll
find out i guess that was funny was that
taking king was it taking king one oh
then i think i did play king's fall
actually okay i didn't talk about it too
then all right yeah what'd you think i
don't remember it
except for the big gods
yeah yeah you still shooting him in the
face pretty cool uh
he's got
they like redid his model so now he has
like feet because before i think he was
just a very corporeal like kind of like
just a torso and they added feet to him
and
i guess that's a hot topic in the
community and some people are like i
don't like that feat it doesn't look
right but some people really like it
some people are like um now that that's
some feet that's some feet right there
get them on wiki feats uh it works wiki
voting feats
um but yeah it's good i'm i'm uh yeah i
think i think the plan with you guys is
like once we do
um the witch queen campaign i'll
probably want to do the dungeons which
um they added after you guys stopped
playing but they're basically like
short three-person mini raids that are
like way less intense and you can okay
those are like a great way to get like a
little raid experience without like
being like time to commit my whole
[ __ ] day to this thing yeah um
and then we'll do some raids and even
then the raids will not be a whole day
because they'll be playing with people
who know how to do it who know how to do
it and well yeah that was the fun thing
about playing raids though is just like
when i did the king's fall one i guess i
was just people we didn't know it was
like where are we supposed to go it is
fun it's like oh there's this little
corridor over here that might lead
somewhere and then you do all this
platforming and then you'd end up
at a boss and we were like how the [ __ ]
do we hurt this thing it's like oh
because you have to transfer these balls
you have to run three laps around the
boss with these balls and then once
you've done that it'll lower its shield
for 30 seconds yup like that stuff is
fun it's fun yeah i agree it's always
been the best part of destiny continues
to be the best part
um and i look forward to doing that with
you lightfall
for sure i'm gonna get there'll be a
raid for that right there will be i will
i will get raid ready for that they make
it they've made it way easier now like
they've they've really tried to like
lower the grind barrier so people can do
that stuff um so i think i think you'll
be able to do it no problem cool no
problem no issue well should we move on
to our topics of the week here yeah
the first one halo infinite season three
delay and split screen co-op cancelled
so i put that in there because i feel
like we all is like halo people have
like talked about our
disappointment with the the
handling of the live service and this is
just like a it's a real big oof for me
it's a shame because they started they
came out of the gates so strong they
really they really did i i just three
four three just not really understand
the concept or i guess the work load
required for
a game service i don't even want to try
to guess i don't even want to guess i
know it's from what i've gathered i know
on at least one aspect of it is that
like their back end tools just don't
seem designed to like rapidly make
changes to the game because like i
remember like day one people were like
the bounty system's bad and like you
just can't get xp after like a certain
day and they're like true and they were
like we will change it it's gonna take
at least a week and that'll be like a
hot fix because like
i think their tools were just so slow to
like make changes and so
it's not like you know like that's
that's why like fortnite is so good it's
because i think like epic like has
designed their tools where they can just
like
push it in there and just like hit go
and it's just like oh naruto's in the
game now call of duty's the same apex is
the same like you really have to design
your game around that idea now yeah
you'd think with like the amount of
steak microsoft and xbox has put into
halo they would have at least
that's unfair to say i'm sure someone's
thought of it but
i don't know maybe it was just like well
it's like too late for that process to
be as streamlined as possible
um it it's such a shame like i
i'll be honest
i don't really want a halo live service
game anyway
but what i do want are new maps
uh so you kind of do want a live service
game
yeah it's more it's less like i guess
yeah
i don't really care about like the
battle pass stuff like i had fun doing
the battle pass stuff originally and
like i like
i i liked how like i liked how you know
i'd get a new halo game there'd be a
certain amount of maps a bunch of
different modes i could play and then
they'd add like a couple maps every
couple months or so and and that's kind
of what it was and and i was totally
cool with that
i really want forge to be honest like
forge is what's gonna get me back into
halo they've people have been messing
with that beta someone recreated andy's
room from tory's story incredible
yeah it's is the beta is the beta out uh
some people have that some people have
it because this is forged beta i think
it must be like a wider release november
you should look up like halo infinite
forge beta like andy's room toy story
like this clip of it like because he's
like oh yeah i made jenga and then i'm
like what the [ __ ] yeah he made it he
made like a working guy and i was like
what the heck but like and someone was
talking about that where they're like
that's going to be the thing
that's the thing that halo infinite
feels like it's missing is like the
community
yeah right like the stuff that's just
like because that's what's kept halo
afloat for all these years is like it
wasn't you don't even need a battle
exactly
my mind was blown in halo 3 when i
finally got online and started
downloading forge maps
like foundry that level foundry where
you could just do whatever you want and
people would just make these super
intricate
um
people like so creative yeah they just
make these intricate obstacle courses
which i thought were so much fun it was
just like all right you gotta crouch
through here and then you gotta make
these jumps like this and then you got
to use this gun to blow up a barrel to
launch you over there and it was like
that that [ __ ] i think is
so cool and it's such a unique way to
use those tools and without that
um
hitler just feels kind of lacking
it is definitely one of those things
that if you took out the battle pass you
took out all the new skins and
customizations and but it was like oh
but forge was there and like i think
halo infinite's like story would be very
different right now well forge in all
the modes because you also forget it
launched with like
half of the modes that are standard in a
halo game missing but i think like this
new update is finally it's adding i
think two more maps and then the first
new weapon that the game has gotten
detachment and argyle are the maps um
that'll be
from now until march 7th but then the
echoes within i'll add a new weapon
which is the bandit which is just like
the dmr i think it kind of looks like it
yeah um
yeah i mean i'm still gonna keep up with
halo because i think that initial
like that that that game was fun that
foundation was fun i had so much fun
playing multiplayer with that i want to
finish campaign but i decided to wait
for co-op
thinking it would be here in a month or
two
well you can do online
that's the bigger that's the bigger one
is the is the shelving of split screen
because they
totally shot themselves in the foot by
saying this is an important thing this
is an important thing that all halo
games in the future will have going
forward that is specifically what bonnie
ross said and like look i get that
things change but like that was like
such
a disaster for them with halo 5 that
they like before infinite was even
announced that was the first thing they
said was don't worry it'll have split
screen and it
they they're canceling the split screen
yeah that's crazy like you know i'm i'm
sympathetic to like the realities of
game development but it's also just like
oh my god like really like yikes like
i'm really wondering like
because they'll probably never
say it publicly out loud and i'm like i
would love to know what the story is on
the back end like why
are they canceling it at all like what
is so
difficult about implementing this that
they're like it is just better if we
shelve
this project than i see i'm willing to
bet it was just too much to have
like
i i bet the xbox one probably played
some role in this because it would be
weird to not have that shift to the xbox
one technically on xbox one um but but i
think it's just too much for one xbox to
handle two people like one xbox one
handling two people that are
far apart because i know that beta they
released i think there was a limit of
like what 200 meters or something which
is also not great they were tethered
which people were complaining about and
i imagine that
like you have to have that tethering
range on a split screen
device like if you're playing split
screen you have to have that tethering
range i imagine i only forgot that this
game also launched on xbox one it's such
a serious accent s game in my mind
um so
i i don't know i i imagine what they did
was they looked at the data of like who
still played split screen on master
chief collection they were like well
we're having trouble getting it running
on the xbox one there's all conjectures
so don't quote me sure but like you're
probably right though i imagine it was
just like
because i mean to be honest like yeah i
want split screen especially because
they said it would be there but like
even if i went through and played all
the old halo games again i wouldn't play
them on split screen i just tell my
friends i play them online you know no
but i i agree that the issue is that
they said it would be there and now it's
not it's it's the fact that they said
they would be there exactly very very
committed publicly they made a
commitment to it yeah and if they hadn't
and they were like hey we're not doing
split screen anymore we looked at the
data whatever xbox one can't do it
doesn't matter what it is i'd be like
all right fine
yeah
i'll move on like as long as co-op is
there which it's
not the bigger problem the fact that i
still can't play co-op because it's like
i want to know i want to finish that
game i really do because i liked it but
i waited because it's a pretty good
campaign yeah but because i was like i
have played every single halo game in
co-op except five i don't play five um
you did not miss you're good
in co-op and i don't wanna play
i i i wanna i wanna experience it fresh
and co-op because that's what's fun to
me about halos yeah
it's a shame that
this is happening
yeah it's a bummer i will say i don't
foresee it happening but uh
chris pereira like put an
somewhat interesting idea into
gamespot's new slack earlier today where
he's like oh i wonder if the
when the activision deal goes through
assuming that it will and i'm pretty
sure at this point that it will
would microsoft xbox ask some of the uh
cod devs to support
343 in
uh
halo or even ask them to make like a
separate halo game that's like
completely different from halo infinite
all the support the poor support studios
that were like we're finally free under
activision and they're like now you make
halo forever
i doubt it it's like there's so many
call of duty support studios and it's
like i'm not sure if xbox would be like
you know what we are still going to
ensure that there's like three different
call of duty's in development
i i think they might share technology
but i don't think they would
they would necessarily be like all right
we're going to take this people yeah i
imagine phil spencer will not want to as
he's kind of said it before like not
want to really mess with like the
business too much of the people they
acquire you know um even if they maybe
should in a couple of cases you know
specifically around activision but
i in the case of like just saying you
now work on this like they probably
probably for the best they don't do that
yeah i think he knows that the next halo
game will be my thing is it's more just
like
for so long halo has been like
microsoft's thing
it's like that and like gears right it's
like in fable for me just i'm not sure
if
i understand what you're saying i'm sure
you're fable
fable was like the reason i got xbox
consoles it's like people think of
master chief when they think of xbox in
the same way that i don't think xbox
thinks that way anymore because they
when they when they close down the line
i think that pretty definitively said
how they felt about fable even though
they're making a new one but
my point is that like they've for so
long hung their hat on like we always
have halo
and i feel like halo has had
been so rocky for so long now
at what point
do you look at like all of this like
kind of bad press around halo and be
like
if we keep
you know putting halo as our premiere
thing
and it's having all this drama around it
at what point do you go this is kind of
really bad for like the brand of xbox as
a whole it's like what if like
you know
every game naughty dog put out just like
kept like having got leaks oh wait
we're just kept having all these like
issues right
like playstation has a lot of mascots
it's true they don't have just one thing
they don't have like just one thing like
they can afford for horizon for ben and
wes to be like you know what it was good
it wasn't fantastic you know like god of
war and last of us part one are still
coming out true that's true that's true
so it's like they're not like xbox it's
like everything's writing on halo right
now but it's like
but you know what i mean like it's just
like at some point i'm like when does
microsoft maybe like not
i don't know not they will not never let
halo go necessarily but like maybe stop
being like maybe we should back off we
should try and find something else maybe
we shouldn't keep trying to put all our
eggs in the halo basket because it's not
really helping us anymore i i feel like
that's gonna have to happen eventually i
mean even if ev it might be for
different reasons though i think the
reason it might happen is just because
they've acquired so many studios and so
many like i mean maybe that's why they
bought activision like call of duty's
our new halo i mean like elder scrolls
six is gonna be they're gonna make that
the microsoft thing right like the xbox
they also can't rely on that right now
because that's what it's usually worth
um
it's not like every bethesda game launch
is perfect either that's true
but but i think it's more that's just
like
like i could see
that
as they as they've been acquiring new
studios maybe they kind of ease off halo
as their mascot and try to like change
the conversation around some of these
other games that will become their
master i mean even like
if the activision deal goes through
which i imagine at this point it
probably will like
call of duty right like even though i
think they've said they don't want to
mess with what that gets released on but
i imagine eventually there's going to
get to a point and they're going to be
like
this is our this is our franchise you
know like we're not putting on places
holding it on pc but we're not putting
on there will be at least one call of
duty game even if it's just like a
single player 10 hour experience that
exclusively releases on xbox that's what
i think at the end of the day it might
be
better for halo if
microsoft like doesn't put that back off
a little bit like give it a break like
that's got to be so much pressure to be
like you are like the thing that's
carrying
xbox for so long like let that team just
like maybe like breathe a little bit
yeah but the devs that they've acquired
they'll release their games at some
point we'll see the outer worlds too
about
star fields uh i hope so i i
i i still believe that
they have a lot of cool things coming
but i there is that part of me yeah
jones and dan jones
i do feel like
a little i don't know it kovit kind of
[ __ ] everything up but it's like that
that little impatient where it's like i
feel like every year xbox is like we
have so many great things yeah next
year's gonna be xbox's your baby and i'm
sitting here being like i do wonder why
it happened it looks like in a year in a
world without covid where i think a lot
of xbox is devs
still xbox's year finally come i've been
waiting since 2014 jordan
i will say psychonauts 2 the best
exclusive i've played so far this
generation of that game well that it
actually wasn't exclusive it did come
out that's true it came out on ps4 never
mind the best thing is you basically
just you're right halo infinite and
forza horizon are um so
skill up tweeted destiny 2 will have
delivered two major expansions and four
seasons worth of content in roughly the
same amount of time it's taken halo
infinite to get forge and cancel couch
co-op
okay when you put it like when you put
it like that absolutely embodied
i guess your earlier point it's like
does halo need to be the
a lot of live service games are like oh
no we update our things like every on
like a three month cycle and halo might
survive on like a sixth month
maybe but the problem is they always
present they never presented it that way
yeah they always presented as like we
are competing in this space yeah i i
think too right like halo was able to
get away with that during the xbox
because what
competition did it have on consoles for
shooters that's what didn't have
competition so it was like friends would
come over and we would play halo and
that is for hours for hours into like 3
a.m
part of it yes halo that original halo
halo 2 even halo 3 were like great
[ __ ] games like i loved playing them
but also
what else were we gonna play you know
like fortnight wasn't a thing like
it wasn't call of duty call of duty 2
came out and that was the first game
where i remember friends coming over and
they want to play that instead of halo
and i was kind of bummed because i was
preferred halo but i was like alright i
guess we're doing call of duty now
and then that happened and now it's like
like the audience
audience wants the audience wants that
they they want a game that they can keep
coming back to which
isn't for me right like i'm okay with a
halo game that just updates
every six months maybe even less like
i'll return to it every now and then
i'll play and i'll be like yeah halo's
still [ __ ] fun
but most of the people that's not what
they want and and
things like fortnite things like call of
duty they've set a precedent
for like how these games should be and
then to your point halo infinite
positioning itself as one of those games
is just kind of like yeah but it's not
and now
the precedent that these other games
have set is hurting your game yeah
you're just you feel like you're behind
the times and they had that opportunity
because it's like
at the fundamentally gameplay wise there
is still no shooter that plays
like
i remember when like the time to kill
like yeah
yeah there's a multiplayer like launched
and everyone just started it's like oh
this this feels so good there's nothing
literally nothing on the market that
feels like this except for master chief
collection right
like split gate i guess yeah
yeah yeah well i think we've talked
enough about i think so yeah
assassin's creed mirage got announced we
don't know too much about or we haven't
seen much from it uh but we're supposed
to see more what september 10th is that
ubisoft yeah that's the ubisoft forward
um but it's supposed to be a it's
supposed to take nods from assassin the
original assassin's creed you play as
bass sim from
valhalla valhalla
uh
and there's no leveling system from what
we understand are you guys interested in
this
if they come out and say this is a
like breezy like
10 to 15 hour game absolute [ __ ] 30
hours 30 hours that's the patience i'll
have if it's more than 30 yeah yeah i
agree with you but like if they were
like like just a nice
quick little jaunt into some assassin's
creed yeah fun i'm i am
all in i mean you know
uh
they said it was just the rumors were
like what i wasn't gonna have like no
leveled tree or anything like that it's
not confirmed it's the reports that
there's no leveling system there's no
male or female option choice there's no
like
ability tree or anything like that it's
just
like to what jake's point earlier it's
like it's like
assassin's creed one through yeah this
is five ac vanilla right like
assassin's creed vanilla
uh i i'm optimistic i i think i'm gonna
have to be optimistic like i
i i liked the rpg games but i never
liked them enough to finish them and
that was always kind of my bigger
complaint like i don't really want to
spend
80 hours 100 hours how long was valhalla
it's a very long game it's a very long
game because like i was
the reason i say 30 hours because i was
pretty engaged in all those games for
about 30 hours i would say
odyssey i was engaged in a little bit
more in um origins i think i would have
finished had i not had to play it event
and then i lost like 40 hours of
progress and i was like all right i'm
done i remember slack messaging cali at
like 3 a.m during the review process for
them like you're probably asleep but
when you wake up i just want you to know
i have found the fourth map in valhalla
and the game isn't slowing down anytime
soon so i'm not sure if i'm gonna pick
people
jesus i'm just calling to let you know
the review will not be finished
like it just won't end it just keeps
going oh my god
um
but i mean jordan you are the the
you've kept up with the franchise you've
finished i've played every
i mean are you are you looking forward
to like a break from the what they've
kind of been doing because you because
you know
i think me and jake are on record not
really being a big fan but you obviously
have enjoyed the recent assassin's
creeds i enjoy it as a
strong strong word yeah like i i really
like the story of assassin's creed but
the gameplay has
i i i'm not even worn out i think i
think tam told me i wasn't allowed to
write it so i like tweeted about it but
when i reviewed like the
last expansion for valhalla there was
like a line where i was like i'm just
really [ __ ] tired of
this
gameplay and i was like imagine if
that's how your review started
i was just like i really like this story
and character but i just i can't keep
playing this game i'm like 170 hours in
and i just can't do it anymore
so like a return to the whole social
stealth thing would be
very nice uh to see and i'm
i'm inclined to believe like the reports
and the rumors just because the image
itself looks like old school assassin's
creed like this looks like an
advertisement we would have gotten like
during like the altair and ezio era yeah
assassin's creed games i think because
for me the setting has always been the
main thing with the assassin's creed
games for me even if i'm not like i've
been sick of the gameplay for a while
but i will still always play those games
because i like walking around egypt i
like walking around greece i like
i like uh walking around was england
when the
like all of that stuff i think is so
cool and i'm excited for the setting
knowing that this
well
if this game is smaller i'm excited to
see how detailed that setting will be
when they're not expected to like fill
out a massive map with all these
different regions and stuff like if it
is just a city with some area outside
but that city is really detailed there's
there's a diverse population that's that
that has like interesting
uh schedules that they attend to like
that that kind of stuff
has me interested and also i think back
to assassin's creed one
and like playing games like hitman like
i wonder if
god would be the assassination will feel
more like that right like i'll actually
be
cause that's kind of what assassin's
creed wanted to do with the original it
was like all right you got to
investigate your target before you kill
them but it ended up just being like i'm
going to sit on a bench and listen to
these people it came out in 2007 like it
was i can't give it too much [ __ ]
because it did a lot of cool things but
like being an actual assassin right
that's what i hope for you know like i i
want a more focused assassin's creed
game where
if i want i can just kind of explore
this world and like when there is an
assassination
i can kind of decide how i want to
do that you know like if i want to be
that assassin who stalks and learns
everything about this character and the
perfect time to kill them cool or if i
just want to like
i don't know jump down from a building
and stab him in the throat and run away
i want to be able to do that i still
can't believe that hitman beat
assassin's creed to like that sort of
video game because i feel like that
style fits the idea to be fair yeah
hitman did it before assassin's creed
true
but like but they lost their
they lost their way for a little bit for
a bit and then they came back with their
very excellent trilogy
but i i would love if this new
assassin's creed was like oh we
basically just
blatantly copy the hitman trilogy so
it's not like as goofy as hitman is and
like the parkour system is much better
than hitman's parkour system but
otherwise he's doing this it's just the
exact like same thing
and there's a hidden blade
i would be more than satisfied with that
i wouldn't even be mad i'd be like
absolutely let's go that sounds great
but but yeah just like more interesting
way like
i don't know like even if it's kind of
dumb like
there's construction happening and your
target walks under it and you just throw
a dagger at it and it falls and kills
everyone's like what the what happened
and then you just walk away like you
blend in with the crowd and walk away
and that's it like that those are the
moments i want an assassin's creed game
yeah you know like when origins was a
thing i was kind of interested because i
was like oh this seems like
a competitor to the witcher 3 and i
really like the witcher 3 but they kind
of wore that out pretty quickly
i don't know
i'm optimistic
and please be short please yeah
um
did you guys also see the rumors about
the remake of assassin's creed one
no i didn't actually
so yeah apparently um
there's a rumor that assassin's creed
mirage will land will launch with like
an expansion pass and at some point in
that expansion pass there will be a
remake of assassin's creed one just like
which will tie into dlc to assassin's
creed mirage that will take place in
some of the locations that assassin's
creed one takes place interesting which
is interesting because i would be super
curious for an assassin's creed one
remake because i feel like that game is
ripe for a remake because there's so
much they could like a proper like a
proper like a resident if it is if it is
a remastered yes then i will not i will
no touch that game there's no way
there's no way they could do that i mean
did you see that there was a thing a
couple years ago or maybe it was a year
ago where like one of the developers on
twitter was talking about how like the
reason why the side missions in
assassins creed won were so like bad and
rushed is because like
somebody asked them to put it in like a
week before the game was to be shipped
or some nonsense like some weird
nonsense where he's like i made those in
like a few days and i was like that
explains when did you sleep everything
i think it was like they were like
something like the
i could be making this up but it was
like the ceo's kid played it and was
like there's not enough to do in this
and they're like make some side missions
or like some nonsense like that and i
was like i believe this i don't know if
this is true but i believe it um
i i i it is a rumor but i kind of
believe it because i think if mirage is
supposed to go back to old school
assassin's creed they'd already have a
improved engine like
that would already be built out in
theory so i imagine designs built out
yeah like i
i imagine that is within the realm of
possibility and i want to say valhalla
takes place
like decades
before
because the assassin's creed one in the
beginning of valhalla look like all
tyree yeah yeah well i mean you play as
boss
yeah
oh okay yeah so like if this is a
prequel it's like oh this is probably
like
200 years or something like that before
yeah
assassin's creed one takes place so it
would make sense that there would be
like some overlap in the setting
somewhat yeah
i wonder if the story's going to try to
tie into assassin's creed one if that's
the case it probably will and it
probably will that's true because now
they're looking back and they're like oh
assassin's creed one and two are like
too ordinary they're not as fantastical
as like i was talking about that with
jordan earlier in the office about how i
was like remember how
the abstergo stuff in assassin's creed
one actually felt kind of like cool and
mysterious and you're like ooh
what's going on like corporate espionage
and and illuminati and like desmond was
just in like two rooms the whole time
you didn't know what was happening and
it felt so interesting and i'm like and
look where we are now it's just a bunch
of nonsense people being reincarnated
and born in new bodies and
all right should we do this last story
yeah let's do the last one right
courtesy of uh sister sight giant bomb
yeah so uh supposedly they're supposed
to be a nintendo direct
sometime soon september this month that
is going to have a lot of zelda
information and
everyone get out get out your nintendo
direct rumor bingo card
because
we might see
a metroid prime trilogy remastered the
minute i saw that i was like this
[ __ ] i don't believe any of this
said the zelda games i've been like
maybe maybe but it's like
metroid prime stuff too i'm like because
that's how it always
way it's always like this stuff that's
somewhat believable and then they get to
oh yeah and metroid prime is trilogy and
i was like yeah [ __ ] you no way
that's on the same level at this point
is like oh and mother three will finally
become local
like i i imagine
to be honest i imagine the metroid prime
trilogy is primed and ready to go i
think they are waiting for the right
time they're gonna wait for when metroid
prime 4 has like
a solid release date or at least
internally they have some gameplay
trailers
and then they'll be like but to hold you
over until then we've remastered sure
and i also believe that
a remake of uh or a remaster of um
i'm sorry poor i guess it wouldn't even
be just of uh
ocarina or not ocarina i can't talk
winner
and tyler
princess or breath of the wild yes i do
believe that those also will come to
switch 100
yeah wasn't
we were supposed to see more about
breath of the wild this year right yes
so because that's what they said in the
last direction so this might be the
direct where it's like and to hold you
over here's wind waker and twilight
princess hd yeah or maybe they'll give
another trailer because like if you have
like a zelda focus direct and then you
don't show any breath of the wild the
gamers will riot so like yeah i don't
think they gotta give songs i don't
think they can show another trailer i
feel like they have to show like a game
play segment at this point oh sure
because they've had two trailers and
that first trailer looked cool but it
just left people with a lot of questions
i don't know i
i just want breath of wild too to come
out so i can see max break that game
right it's like oh yeah
um but anyway this report came from jeff
grubb of gamespot
um sorry who jeff grubb of uh giant bomb
oh i don't want to read all of this but
yeah apparently it's supposed to be a
big zelda direct which
i hope it's right and i believed it
until i saw metroid stuff uh would you
guys would you guys play those again
i would play wind waker 100 i would play
that game again twilight princess
probably not absolutely like literally
the exact opposite
i don't feel as strongly negatively
towards twilight princess but
i
do feel like i
where i i feel like i need more time and
because i did play it on wii u
i would like
where wind waker i could like pick up
any time of the day todd princess i
think i'm like annie a little bit it's
hard though both wind waker and twilight
princess have the same problem of like
every time i want to try to jump back
into those games i forget i'm like oh
right the first like hour and a half of
both of these games is so [ __ ] slow
yes but
forever twilight princess is way worse
round up some cattle
no no i don't i really don't i also i
don't
i want them to do it but i don't know if
they will i really want them to port
those um 3ds versions of uh ocarina and
majora's to
the yeah which is well i think that all
of them on switch
versions of those games and i think that
would be cool if they did that
well i don't know anything left to say
about the nintendo direct sorry i yawned
right then
i'm really really excited really excited
yeah really uh
yeah i
believe
i don't know i'm i'm gonna say i'm like
80 believe it uh except for the
the metroid prime part i won't believe i
don't yeah i i think
i i think the reason we're getting um we
might be getting uh wind waker and
twilight princess is because they're
going to announce the delay for breath
of the wild too
that's my guess because i don't
it's nintendo and i don't
i feel like they they would
strategically wait to give these games
to people because they know people want
them sure right and i feel like the best
time to do it is when they have to say
hey we have to push this you're not
going to we have to push this game back
even longer does breath wild 2 even have
like a 20 23 like
date or anything or is it just kind of
in the ether of like it's
i think i'm just kind of in the eve
there but
i think
i think that game's gonna take even
longer and that's why yeah
um all right
question of the week we'll make this
quick so we can get out of here and wrap
this thing up but
what's been your favorite gaming
experience with someone that doesn't
typically play video games now this is
an easy this is an easy answer for me
but if you guys have something i will
throw the floor to you
uh i played through
uh star wars nightstall republic with my
mom because she's a huge star wars fan
okay but doesn't play games and i was
like
national republic fantastic star wars
game great story i think you'd really
like it so did she uh she did she had a
really good time with it and then we
afterwards started playing through mass
effect
uh but got we did one and then we got
like halfway through two and then i like
went to college and never finished it
unfortunately but um
those were fun i had a really good time
yeah after mom um
the other experience i'd have it's less
of like
a specific playing a game but i just
always think about how like
my dad always loves to ask me about like
what the newest games are because he
just is really interested in how good
they look yeah so he's a tech yeah so
he'll always be like oh i heard the new
uh like i remember like assassin's creed
for a while or just like the last of us
or whatever he'd be like oh that game
looks really good i'm like yeah it looks
great you know new hardware like so i
just it's always funny it's a very dad
thing to do yeah and i always just love
that about him
i would say my my mom
really enjoys watching me play
assassin's creed because for her she was
like oh this is like the pinnacle of
like graphical excellence and i had to
keep her mind i'm like it's
it's not
like
like some of the games are very pretty
but maybe assassin's creed one at the
time i remember yeah but it was one of
those things where since assassin's
creed was coming out every single year
like my mom could always expect like oh
during like the christmas break when
jordan doesn't have school he's playing
the new yeah
to like figure out where graphics were
in terms of video games that's funny um
mine's rock band i remember when i got
that oh yeah i got that for christmas
and just
everyone like all my family
like was super into it friends who came
over who didn't play video games was
like yeah we're just gonna play rock
band and we'd i remember rock band
beatles in particular being a big oh
sure um
but yeah like those games i remember
just
i was like the cool house for a bit
because i had the whole setup oh yeah
yeah
rock paper scissors guitar hero wii
sports guitar hero yeah it's probably a
good one too wii sports
kind of
wii sports was more like i showed it to
my parents and non-gamer friends and
they really liked it and i was like this
is kind of simple for me i'm going to do
other stuff and they kept playing it
they're like no we sports is excellent
i'm like sure whatever i'm going to play
mass effect 2 like
i play real game i remember one time i
was visiting my grandma in washington
and she was like she was like oh do you
mind like going through this box and
like helping me clean stuff out
and and i was going through and she had
a ds in there she'd never play games at
all and i was like grandma why do you
have a ds and she was like oh the the
game called cookie mama interested me
[ __ ] mama and i was like i was like
she was like did you play it and she was
like i played a little bit of it but i
didn't like it and she was like you can
have it if you want so i got a ds
because she was just like i don't really
don't play this game don't care so i'm
like all right i'll take it i did play
wii sports once with my grandparents and
my grandma did almost destroy the tv
because she did not put this slip on
like it hit it went
just barely to the left of it i was like
okay we're done playing yeah that's it
that's it for fun times everyone
all right well that's been episode two
of the jake jordan john luke podcast
we'll be back next week with uh gamespot
after dark hopefully tomorrow lucy will
be back lucy's maybe not she's not
feeling great yeah but tomorrow i think
she'll be back
so we'll see how busy he is yeah
if not it'll be episode three of the
jake jordan only podcast yeah he's very
busy with the uh the mobile swipe
showcase which will be airing um the
same day uh i believe it's next thursday
at 10 a.m
i think i have that right hopefully not
the same time as the nintendo direct if
it happens right
oh my god what do you think wait so are
we gonna do swipe then possibly nintendo
direct and then just immediately go
under dark at the all on the same day
the event will take place during the the
week beginning september 12th so no not
the same day no it'd be after yeah we're
good we're good okay
um
but anyway
before we go jordan anything you want to
plug
uh please read my review of flintlock
please and your review preview preview
preview preview haven't haven't reviewed
it yet yeah i i don't know i'm so tired
so much [ __ ] is going on
but yeah i i got nothing else i got
nothing else i can talk about yet all
right yeah some things i can't talk
about either sean luke um
yeah i got a game i'm playing that i
can't talk about but i can talk about
that we can't talk about
i can if you if you look at what's up
coming up really soon like in maybe the
next week or so you could figure it out
figure out what i may be playing and
i'll probably have things to say about
it
really soon so there you go
cool yeah um i've got a bunch of last of
us stuff up we did a review which you
can check out uh
i put a lot of time and effort into that
review i hope it i hope it shows uh
really proud of how that came out it's a
very good review that's a very good one
um
i have there's a graphics comparison
between the two that jean-luc helped me
with that you should also check out if
you want to see how good it actually
looks
there's also a is the last of us part
two worth it that just went up that uh
is pretty good basically that just
outlines all of the new stuff and then
from there you can decide if you think
it's worth it or not
uh and then there's some gameplay some
4k gameplay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you